I want to start with a sincere
congratulations for doing the impossible
um but you've been talking all day about
yourself and now I'm going to change it
up
um I am curious uh what was it like
watching Creed 3 for the first time and
what notes did you give Michael I'm not
answering that bro I'm not answering
that yes that's crazy
I mean I I asked her what it was like
fantastic that's what it was like I I
was filled with um a lot of Pride for
for Mike uh
for Jonathan
for Tasha
for Felicia
um and and for for the young starter
everybody's about to meet that players
Amara
um but it was I was filled with it with
a with a deep deep deep sense of Pride
for all of them and my brother
um my baby brother who who wrote the
script
um in in uh along along with uh Zach
Balon who wrote King Richard I was just
proud of them all you know and and I
called Mike and told him
um I'm not gonna get into the knowledge
I'm just messing around but like uh I I
heard it turned out great it's still
working on it man but it's I think it's
it's a unique movie yeah